stay tuned for the rest of the video but
first a word from our sponsor
this video brought to you by frag pro
shooter one of the best mobile shooter
games of 2020 designed for mobile
platforms with over 60 million players
worldwide
and 1 million playing at any given time
each day
in frag you can collect over 80 unique
characters with their own powers
create your deck to build your strategy
and destroy enemy bunkers
each new version of the game features a
new character like the latest edition
stella the good witch who was summoned
to queen unicorn's court after realizing
peace couldn't be kept in her absence
she has the power to shoot a star from
her broom that explodes on impact for
major damage
the game also features several unique
modes including payload where you can be
the first player to escort your cart to
the center of the map and win
or slow down the enemies cart to get an
advantage you can join clubs to play
with your friends and frag together
and there are free rewards for you only
thanks to the link in the description
even for those who've already installed
frag
so see you there now back to the video
[Music]
so anyway it was all over the ceiling
and the school janitor wanted like
nothing to do with it but i had an alibi
because i had the most reading hours
that week so the teacher took me and a
few other kids to sonic for lunch that
day
are you talking about the alien
secretive resin
uh yes all right cannon space trucker
we got a distress call from this vessel
and it's our job to seek and destroy
any alien sons of [ __ ] so have you
ever seen one of these things before i
hear they're like stabby wet skeleton
penis monsters
yeah they're pretty moist for some
reason but they're not that bad
just look at this
anytime i've seen them they're pretty
lame
[Music]
alien is the landmark 1979 sci-fi
horror film that stun audiences the
world over by taking the hopeful
peaceful setting of deep space
exploration and making it [ __ ] scary
since then it's gone on to be one of the
most iconic movie franchises of all time
the series is most known for its grim
gritty dystopian future setting
its mysterious masterfully designed
alien antagonist and its emphasis on
strong female leads
the series has easily one of the coolest
fictional creatures in one of the most
interesting settings and it seems like a
no-brainer to translate that to video
games
allowing you to explore this oppressive
atmosphere and simulate battling the
deadly space bug yourself would be a
blast if handled properly
and with a franchise license this
well-known and successful
you just know they have to have tried it
a million times so which ones showed us
how terrifying this creature is over the
years
to answer that we'll have to look back
at some of the earliest appearances of
the terrifying black penis monster
on the commodore 64. oh boy
talk about some humble beginnings being
that we can't exactly get our hands on a
lot of these games due to them being
offline
impossible to emulate or incredibly rare
bear with us if we can only give a
surface level look at some of the
smaller entries in the series
we may also talk about one or two
versions of a game if there's like 15
ports of it this video has already been
long enough without a review so
let's get to it before you click off oh
god oh geez alien began life as a game
franchise on the atari 2600
with a not very good pac-man clone that
sometimes rips off frogger too
after that we get to alien on the
commodore 64 which is
kind of like a text-based adventure game
with incredibly basic graphics to
visualize the action
at least that sprite looks like the
alien this time
next up aliens the computer game also on
the commodore
based on the second movie starting to
kind of look like a game
flying sequences environments to explore
and some basic combat and even a rough
recreation of scenes from the movie
the catch is that this game is 20 action
80
hud good god aliens alien 2 is a neat
little side scroller shooter on the msx
where you play as ripley blasting
through aliens and trying to save newt
oh look at how prejudice killed off
screen in the sequel
well all these are let's say quaint
attempts at creating a game based off
the franchise but they didn't really
have that same level of excitement they
certainly lacked the technology to mimic
the film's memorable visuals and
atmosphere
we didn't capture that until your turn
bozo get in there i suck at side
scrollers
until oh yeah now this is more of my
alley
aliens the arcade game was released in
1990 and developed by konami
remember when they used to make video
games this side-scrolling shooter just
oozes bodacity from the second you pop
in that arcade token it's
non-stop breakneck speed of shooting
down all sorts of xenomorphs
this being an arcade game keeping the
experience fresh and well paced
is a much more crucial element than it
normally would be in a console game
the primary form of gameplay is walking
from left to right and shooting down
anything with a heartbeat but soon
enough you'll be switching to a third
person perspective
where you're shooting enemies in the
background or riding an apc as you rush
your way across a highway to rescue nuke
mowing down aliens is really satisfying
with a smart gun
but you can pick up other weapons like a
flamethrower or rocket launcher
you may have noticed that the developers
took some freedom with character design
ripley's hair is totally a different
color but that's easily forgivable when
you get
awesome variants of the xenomorphs you
won't find these in the movies
but i totally buy these different breeds
of aliens that may have resulted from a
facehugger latching itself to a certain
animal or a different alien that's
indigenous to the planet
i also love the different funky colors
on these xenos like purple and green
they make the sprites really pop out of
the screen and make for some really sick
action figures
best of all are all the different bosses
you know you have a good boss design
when it comes out of the shadows and the
first thing you say
is what the hell is that my favorite one
is this one that looks like a giant rib
cage with gross tentacles coming out of
it
but of course there's only one way to
end an aliens game
and that's where the boss fight against
the queen while manning a power loader
and forcing that [ __ ] out into the void
of space
aliens the arcade game is a fun action
romp that can be beaten in around 30
minutes
it's just the right length so it doesn't
feel dragged out and it stays fresh from
beginning to end
also thank god for emulators because
this thing would have eaten a boatload
of my quarters
if you thought the alien queen laid an
overwhelming amount of x-ax and aliens
that's nothing compared to how many
versions of alien 3
probe software developed there are seven
versions of alien 3 spread across
different platforms with an 8th
developed by bit studios for the gameboy
but i'm going to be focusing on the snes
version
since it seems to be the most popular
one this game managed to impress me in
multiple ways
first the visuals i mean i'm easily
impressed with 16-bit era video games so
this is no surprise to me
i think games of this graphic style will
forever stand the test of time
just look at games like super metroid
and donkey kong country timeless
i love how they use effects like rain
and smog and that parallax effect to add
some depth
i wasn't expecting this game to be as
open as it is you don't simply go from
left to right and reach the end of the
level
you walk up to a terminal and you have a
list of missions that you can take upon
in any order you wish when you accept
the mission your objectives will be
marked on your map
and it's up to you what route you want
to take it can be easy to get lost
though
because once you leave the terminal you
don't have access to a map
so you gotta keep in mind where your
objectives are located in relation to
your position on the map
if you do manage to get lost you can
just reach one of the multiple levels on
the map
and reorient yourself but still it can
be a little annoying
i wish i could just pull up the map any
time i wanted
missions are pretty varied to give you
some examples some have you rescuing
prisoners
repairing leaky pipes or destroying some
exacts
you gotta be careful not to be a little
too trigger happy because ammunition is
limited
and enemies are plentiful if you use up
all your ammo or carelessly take damage
it can be a while before you come across
the next ammo or health pickup
this resulted in some pretty tense
moments where i was trying really hard
to not take a hit from even the smallest
facehugger
as i was desperately trying to find a
health pack there are also some
platforming elements which are the
weakest part of this game because ripley
has a really awkward jump
it's not egregious by any means but it
can sometimes be a little tough to land
on a moving platform
i did like that you have the ability to
cling onto pipes and move across them
like monkey bars
while still having the ability to shoot
that's always badass
like many retro games this is no walk in
the park and it can be a challenge for
even the toughest and meanest of space
marines
however through dying in this game i did
find what is easily the best
part of the alien 3 video game and
that's getting to hear bill paxton's
famous
game in the game over screen
ever wondered how you would fare as a
colonial marine well do i have news for
you
light gun rail shooters brings you
closer than ever before to living out
your fantasies of pumping lead into
space bugs
the first ever aliens like gun arcade
game was alien 3 the gun
this game is a light adaptation of you
guessed it alien 3
instead it's told from the perspective
of two marines if you so happen to have
a co-op buddy
you go through different environments of
fiorina 161 as you mow down an
assortment of xenomorphs
as well as some robots and weyland
troops at the end of each level you face
off against the boss
they're not the most inventive bosses
sometimes being a bigger version of a
facehugger or a regular old xenomorph
i do like that when you clear stage
you're given a rank depending on your
performance
it really incentivizes you to go all out
and impress all the ladies in your local
dave and busters
pro tip don't shoot the prisoners
sorry guy at the end of the game you
fight a mysterious man that comes in to
retrieve the alien specimen
after you take him down a bunch of
wailing troops show up to riddle you
with bullets
john marston's style you served well
maureen
now leave your initials and turn in your
well-earned tickets for a xenomorph
plushie
alien's extermination is an arcade rail
shooter from 2006 and i gotta say
this series lends itself incredibly well
to that format of gameplay
it's all about a bunch of melee monsters
of various sizes and types running at
you down
corridors while the main characters blow
them apart with sci-fi
future guns they were practically made
for this
so this game weirdly enough has the same
setup as another game on our list
a group of marines go back to the space
colony hadley's hope
which should be a big smoking crater but
whatever and needlessly fight more
aliens even though they could have just
left them alone or nuked it from orbit
it's the only way to be sure these
environments are good at evoking the
look of the movie but not too many of
them feel all that familiar beyond that
the alien types are pretty standard
until you get to this monstrosity
how exactly an alien dragon came to be
is a mystery to me
but it makes for a neat boss fight i
suppose to mix things up you also fight
a few combat androids including one and
a power loader with a buzz saw
the game ends with a nice little boss
against an alien queen where you set up
a nuke
i bet you could have just done that you
didn't have to
be on the ground and then fly away
successfully
well given how much these games seem to
respect the source material
i'm sure that explosion was just really
bright but didn't actually burn
anything so all these aliens are just
going to be seeing spots for a few hours
i may be jumping a few years ahead but
it felt right to package these games
together
aliens armageddon is the next rail
shooter in the series from 2014.
this game is about what would happen if
aliens actually got to earth
like that comic book aliens book 1 which
is to say
[Music]
now you and your space marine bros are
in a mad dash through a futuristic city
to get to a big spaceship where you guys
can bail on this planet
along the way you fight of course some
recognizable bio-organic bad guys
but because every species creates a
different type of alien when implanted
by the facehuggers
there are a lot of different types to
battle some of these i have no idea how
the hell they could have been made
like what animal makes this a a rhino
are these ones like eels where did they
get wings
can a facehugger manage to wrap itself
around a pterodactyl
but is this one the size of a house and
that was another dragon alien but it's
like 50 times bigger oh my god
but anyway i really like this game when
i played it a few years ago at the chuck
e cheese with my dad
it was cool that the blasters looked
just like the pulse rifles from the
movie
it's pretty similar to the terminator
rail shooter that came out shortly
before this by the same developer
but it still fits together i like the
idea of fighting aliens in an urban city
environment since we don't really get to
see that often
if the world ever goes back to being
normal again like before the alien
parasites invaded
i'd love to hit up an arcade machine of
this one again
what is it now herrickson
aliens a comic book adventure is a
point-and-click adventure game released
in 1995 and developed by cryo
interactive entertainment
despite its title there's nothing about
this game that screams comic book to me
i expected a graphical style that
invoked the medium things like panels
speech bubbles onomatopoeia
and flipping pages as the story plays
out the only thing that deems this game
a comic book adventure is that it's a
pseudo follow-up to aliens labyrinth
a comic book published by darkhorse in
the early 90s which is an
awesome read by the way it's one of the
most gruesome alien comics i've read
and they dig into some really
interesting aspects like how the alien
hive mind works
but you're better off thinking of this
game and comic as two totally separate
stories
for the most part the game has its own
cast of characters but some characters
share the same name as some found in the
comic
even though they're two totally
different characters that have nothing
to do with each other
besides the shared name like lieutenant
mcginnis who is a technician in the
space station inominada
in the book and lieutenant mcginnis who
is a microbiologist aboard the uss
sheridan in the game
these discrepancies may not be a huge
deal but they're enough to cause
confusion
i wish the game would just drop the
comic book part from the title and tell
a completely original story instead
you play as henry herrickson a clear nod
to lance henriksen who plays the android
bishop in aliens
in classic alien fashion the story
begins with the crew members of the uss
sheridan waking up from cryosleep and
responding to a distress call from a
nearby planet
the rest of the crew consists of the
aforementioned mcginnis the
microbiologist
williams captain and pilot of the ship
and finally o'connor
science officer and number one xenomorph
fanboy
i trust you o'connor what's the problem
chum
need a little reassurance is it the idea
that we might meet up with aliens that
frightens you
these guys are a bunch of [ __ ] they
waste no time in being some of the most
unlikable characters i've interacted
with in a video game
they take every opportunity they can to
insult you
tell you how incompetent you are at your
job and make the most condescending
remarks
tell me frankly captain what do you
think of me you don't know how to handle
a woman
but otherwise you're okay say cat you
think i'm a good leader
all you've done so far is talk pretty
good at that
have you looked at yourself lately you
ugly slob i've got things to do damn it
i've got no problems muscle head but you
seem to have a massive one
oh connor do you think i'm a good enough
leader you're the primitive prototype
of a colonial marine leader you're not
too bright and you stick to orders
no one expects any more all right
it doesn't help that harrison is also
the most insecure protagonist i've
played as
a lot of his dialogue options consist of
questions like what do you think of me
how do i look geez i don't know how you
put up with me
for crying out loud man you've been
appointed as the leader for this rescue
mission
instill some confidence in your
crewmates but to be fair
herrickson isn't the most pleasant guy
either he often speaks with a lot of
aggression
and you get lovely dialogue options such
as do you think the doctor is good in
bed
hey let's go beat up that science nerd
i'm gonna kick your teeth in
yeah these are exactly the kind of
people i want to be stuck in space with
for months at a time
like i said before it's strange to me
that this game misses the
opportunity of taking upon a more comic
booky aesthetic
instead the game combines 2d
illustrations for the characters
and 3d rendered environments i'm not
about to tear apart someone else's
artwork
god knows i can't do any better but man
some of the expressions on the
characters are so extreme
that they look kind of freaky [ __ ]
he's dying mcginnis you're at a 13
i need you to bring it down to like a
seven i think the cg on most
environments look
pretty good especially in ones with
heavy shadows and interesting lighting
when characters are animated they do
move really awkward and stiff
kind of bordering the line of stop
motion but it wasn't offensively bad
what was is how disorienting the camera
angles can get
when you transition from one scene to
another you often get these hard cuts
that change to a totally different angle
but there's no continuous shot and the
fact that herrickson doesn't move in
real time
losing my place in the environment
happened to me often
this is really annoying when you're
trying to make your way across a simple
hallway
or when dealing with the game's most
annoying feature a time limit
there are several sections in this game
where you can't leisurely explore the
environment or take your time solving a
puzzle
the game will cut to a short cut scene
letting you know that death is around
the corner
the game immediately starts with one of
these scenarios when you wake up from
cryosleep
the ship is in danger of colliding with
a bunch of asteroids
there's no visual representation like an
on-screen timer
letting you know how much time you have
left so you really have to focus on
completing the mission before being
greeted by a game over screen
that then boots you back to the main
menu don't be like me
save often i'll admit this is a good way
of setting up suspense
and putting some pressure on the player
cutting to an ominous shot of asteroids
hurling toward your ship
or xenomorphs trying to break down a
door can be pretty stress-inducing
but this feature quickly starts to get
annoying the further you get into the
game
and environments get bigger and puzzles
more obscure
finding key items and figuring out what
to do with them is the main gameplay
loop of this game
solving these puzzles is pretty
straightforward in the beginning but
then they start to get really confusing
when you pick up generic computer parts
or just random tech
in a setting where there's a computer
terminal in almost every room you enter
it starts to feel more like guesswork
than puzzle solving
combat in comic book adventure is barely
worth talking about
when you encounter an enemy the game
changes perspective into an isometric
diablo-style view
combating the enemy is as simple as
equipping a weapon from your inventory
and right-clicking where you want to
attack on the grid-based layout
you also have the ability to move around
to avoid attacks in this mode
it's far from an engaging combat system
i never was the biggest fan of
point-and-click adventure games
the ones i've enjoyed the most are the
more streamlined telltale games
that have a bigger focus on a branching
story depending on your dialogue choices
and less on pixel perfect item hunting
sadly
aliens a comic book adventure isn't
going to be the one to win me over on
this genre
but i think there is potential here a
choice driven game where you build
relationships with your crewmates
in the vast emptiness of space where no
one can hear
you know what i mean it sounds like a
cool idea
[Music]
i get that you're trying to calm me down
man but i'm hearing noises all around us
i keep stepping in squishy stuff that's
giving me flashbacks to fifth grade
any food left over aliens don't eat that
right
nah just coffee it's the only good thing
on this ship anyway
i was hoping for some eggs hey which arm
hurts when you're having a heart attack
why does your arm hurt no but my chest
does
wait something
you lock that [ __ ] up mendoza and please
don't say eggs again
those things have a nasty tendency to
oh [ __ ] geez we really stuck you with
all the retro stuff because i can't run
emulators
yeah the first half of this review is
pretty diego heavy
you want to read my review of alien
trilogy so like
you wrote it but i'll be saying it just
so we can have more
speaking parts for me in the early parts
of this video yeah
basically should i do it a brooklyn
accent please god no
alien trilogy voiced by me
but written by diego the first proper
first person shooter based on alien came
in the form of alien trilogy
released in 1996 for playstation sega
saturn
and dos prober entertainment took the
helm for this one
the title this game led me or diego
rather to believe that this game was one
big adaptation of the first three alien
movies
retelling the events in chronological
order instead what we have here is more
of an amalgamation of the first three
films
alien trilogy takes elements from each
movie and uses them to more or less tell
an original story
a very basic one at that this even
reflects in the player character
we assume control of ellen ripley who's
a colonial marine in this game
and is sporting a shaved head fans of
the series won't look past the fact that
ripley was never a marine in the movies
so again some inspiration from the
supporting cast of badass marines from
alien
some from alien 3 for ripley's
appearance and we have this phony
frankenstein version of ripley as our
main character for this game
as ripley were tasked with going through
different environments from the movies
such as lv426
fiorina 161 the derelict ship and
clearing them of any alien organisms
most of this game's story is delivered
through text boxes at the beginning of
each level
detailing your objectives on that
mission but there isn't really much
context beyond
shoot the ugly space monsters
occasionally you're treated to a cgi
cutscene
setting up the locale for the next
chapter in the game they don't do much
in regard to moving the plot forward
but there's something to look forward to
after you've cleared the previous
chapter
alien trilogy is what can effectively be
described as a doom clone
copycats of the legendary first person
shooter were as plentiful back in the
day as they still are today
with good reason this style of gameplay
has aged like fine wine
it's a very basic gameplay style but one
that can accommodate for many different
genres
horror sci-fi fantasy you name it the
most prominent aspect of a doom clone is
probably its graphic style which
consists of npcs
items and the player character's hands
and weapons being a 2d sprite in a 3d
environment
i think diego thinks this graphic style
will stand the test of time
it's such a stylized look and even its
shortcomings are easily forgivable
like the fact that these sprites lose
detail and get uglier the closer you get
to them
as time went on and with the
introduction of analog sticks these
games started to give players more
control when it came to aiming
but during their infancy aiming was
limited to the x-axis
as someone who is more familiar what the
[ __ ] phoenix what are you why are you
reading the script hey this is supposed
to be me reading diego's script get it
get the hell out of here get off
get out all right as someone who is more
familiar with modern fps games i was
concerned that the limitation would
result in the gameplay feeling really
shallow
but the game works around that
limitation by having xenomorphs and
facehuggers approaching you in a zigzag
pattern
so you have to stay one step ahead and
anticipate these moves in order to
efficiently land your shots diego was
impressed by the fact that despite this
game coming out before the playstation
got its first dual analog controller
it still managed to have an intuitive
control scheme walking back and forth
and turning is done with the d-pad
strafing left and right is mapped to the
l1 and r1 buttons respectively
it goes without saying that you'll be
coming across the likes of xenomorphs
face huggers chest bursters and the dog
or ox alien hybrid
depending on which cut of alien 3 you
prefer you'll also fight some humanoid
enemies like infected colonists
androids and those weyland yutani dudes
in bulky white armor that show up at the
end of alien 3.
facehuggers are surprisingly feeble here
normally i'd be well diego would be
paranoid to these little critters
sneaking up on me for an instant death
but in this game they're more of a mild
annoyance obstructing your view for a
couple of seconds and doing very little
damage
the worst offense is the alien queen the
final level of each of the three
chapters
is a boss fight against the queen what
is supposed to be an unstoppable killing
machine
unable to be bested amounts to a boss
fight where i just stand there and shoot
it until she drops dead
there's an animation of her taking
damage that stun locks her as long as
you keep shooting
making her completely defenseless so
much for the perfect organism
i ad-libbed that that wasn't in the
script levels consist of simple
objectives
like clear out the area of xenomorphs
activate some switches
collect id tags or find a stash of
weapons
checking these objectives off is made
easy with the use of the game's in-game
map
that marks down any points of interest
like breakable crates doors and switches
every few levels you're given the chance
to stock up on supplies in a sort of
bonus level
you have 60 seconds to run around and
pick up as many items as you can before
time runs out
this is all well and good but the game
quickly becomes stale
there are 30 levels in total which
results in an average time to beat of 8
hours
that may sound standard but the game
does very little to keep the experience
fresh
the game frequently cycles the same four
objectives throughout its levels
and when narrative elements are as few
as they are you find yourself glancing
at your watch wondering when the game is
going to start wrapping things up
i think having something as simple as 2d
cutscenes with still images and some vo
every couple of levels or so
could have gone a long way to keeping me
more engaged i
diego don't want to be too harsh on
alien trilogy because despite its
shortcomings it's still a good first
person shooter that hasn't aged all that
poorly
with some narrative context i would
easily recommend this game to any fans
of the franchise it's a strong
foundation for future alien first person
shooters to come
aliens online this one's a neat little
doom clone with some early online
capabilities
with one team playing his space marines
and the other is various types of alien
enemies
this one went offline permanently so
whatever footage is online is
what you get i like how the ui for this
game looks more like a stream layout
than a hud
it's even got a face cam all it's
missing is a chat making mean comments
wow after four years the alien was able
to turn his head slightly
yeah this wouldn't have been totally
confusing and annoying back then
slowing things down and creeping into a
more survival horror experience
alien resurrection is a late ps1 game
and even later movie tie-in
released three years after the film and
developed by argonaut games
alien resurrection went through several
stages at one point being a third person
action game akin to tomb raider
it eventually settled on being a slow
paced first person shooter
i was blown away with how well it holds
up graphically it captures the tone of
the film
with its dimly lit corridors and
mutilated bodies with their chest burst
open
hinting at the deadly monsters you will
inevitably face
that paired with screams echoing through
hallways footsteps scurrying inside
events
and the constant beep of your motion
tractor results in an experience that
as the game advises is best played in
the dark
unfortunately alien resurrection is held
back by brutal difficulty
and unforgiving save points alien
resurrection came out during a time
where first person shooters on consoles
were uncommon
it's no secret that fps games dominated
the pc gaming space
but argonaut games decided to bring that
experience to consoles with a control
scheme to redefine first person shooters
on consoles
sadly this control scheme just didn't
jive with some players
claiming that it didn't make sense and
was far too clunky
let me take you back to the distant past
of the year 2000
with an excerpt from a gamespot review
of alien resurrection
quote the game's control setup is his
most terrifying element
the left analog stick moves you forward
back and strafes right and left
while the right analog stick turns you
and can be used to look up and down
too often you'll turn to face a foe and
find that your weapon is aimed at the
floor or
ceiling while the alien gleefully hacks
away at your midsection
end quote man the guys at argonaut games
were out of their minds
that control scheme would never catch on
alright it's easy to poke fun at a
review from a time when a new control
scheme was being introduced
and it seemed so obtuse to players back
in the day
just a year later halo would use the
same control scheme
and everyone reveled its innovation i
did experience some difficulty
controlling the camera in my first few
minutes
but it was more of a sensitivity problem
than a control scheme one
thankfully alien resurrection offers
mouse support
and not with a weird hack or mod
playstation had an official mouse
periphery which caught a list of games
supported
games like point and click adventures
rts games
and of course fps games this is the way
i
chose to play alien resurrection and i
can wholeheartedly say that it is the
best way to play it
this game expertly sets the stage with a
setting that is ripped straight from the
movies
the usm auriga makes for the perfect
setting to set a horror game in
the problem is that these environments
start to blend faster than a xenomorph's
growth spurt
pick a level from the very beginning of
the game and one from seven hours in
and good luck picking out differences
between them when the game doesn't offer
new visuals to look forward to when you
beat a level
it quickly makes the experience feel
repetitive
the fact that levels can stretch over an
hour and the game asks you to backtrack
through rooms and hallways that all look
identical
it will have you running in circles this
is a shame because i usually like when
games ask me to backtrack explore and
solve environmental puzzles
but those aren't games that have
distinct memorable environments
that allow you to draw a mental map
because the rooms and hallways are so
different from one another
this also could have easily been solved
if alien resurrection
offered an in-game map resource
management is a crucial element here
recklessly shoot your pulse rifle not
making the most of each bullet
or take hits like you have regenerating
health and you'll find yourself in a
heap of trouble
countless times i found myself inching
my way through the spaceship
jumping and bursting pipes counting
every single med pack and bullet left in
my inventory
ammo gets especially scarce in later
levels the pistol
does have unlimited ammo but it's so
weak against xenomorphs that you might
as well be shooting spitballs at them
it's best used against x-ax and
facehuggers
getting face-hugged in this game doesn't
result in just simply taking damage or
instantly dying
your character passes out and when you
come to you'll notice an extra meter
underneath your health bar
at this time you are impregnating with a
xenomorph embryo and when that meter
runs out
the little bastard bursts out of your
chest and then you die
to avoid this you can pick up an item
called the portable auto dock this
device will irradiate the embryo inside
you and kill it
where does it go once it's dead i find
it best not to ask
but this feature goes even deeper if you
have an embryo inside of you
xenomorphs will be less aggressive
towards you sometimes
outright ignoring you if not for a short
time
this has its obvious strategic
implications you can take advantage of
these docile moments of the xenos to do
some damage
the xenomorphs ai isn't the most
advanced thing in the world
for the most part they just rush at you
from the front but they do have their
cutting moments of sneaking up behind
you and following you into vents
on the other hand ladders seem to be
their biggest weakness
if you climb up or down a ladder while
they're chasing you consider yourself
victorious
despite being able to cling to walls
aliens will just stare at ladders as you
empty a clip
into them i feel really conflicted about
this game
i think it does a great job building
tension and keeping the player on edge
but damn does it waste no time in
ramping up his difficulty xenomorphs can
be taken off fairly easy with a pulse
rifle
but you have to be quick and not let
them get too close they will make quick
work of you and running
is not an option it literally isn't
you're stuck with a painfully slow walk
throughout the whole game
there's also no stealth system so don't
bother hiding
this harsh difficulty is made even worse
by the manual save points
that are few and far between i really
like manual save points in horror games
i think they add a lot of suspense when
you go a while without running
into one and you've made substantial
progress walking into a safe room
and letting out that sigh of relief are
some of my favorite moments in horror
games but alien resurrection
is far too stingy when it comes to save
points i experienced instances
where i wouldn't come a save point for
up to 30 minutes that's a lot of game
time to replay if i were to die
game time where i'm constantly stressed
about the troubles i can run into
with every step i take that kind of
stress is more induced with frustration
rather than the good kind that comes
with being spooked for a game that's
based on a movie
it's devoid of many narrative elements
for one
there isn't any voice acting except at
the very beginning of the game and once
more at the end
dialogue is mostly delivered through
text within cutscenes
that mainly consist of a computer
terminal displaying a character portrait
that resembles the actors as much as a
facehugger respects your personal space
you get to play as different characters
from the movies such as call
and the stefano they don't offer unique
abilities but they do have some weapons
that are exclusive to them
to be frank had i not been giving the
context of the movie i probably wouldn't
know what the hell was even going on in
this game
what i do know is that this game really
likes the plot point where ripley mercy
kills one of her clones
almost every mission i played had me
destroy
ripley clowns didn't matter who i was
playing as ripley being a clone in alien
resurrection
was a really dumb choice so maybe this
game having you kill so many of them
is symbolic of the fans disdain alien
resurrection is the kind of game you
want to see succeed
it has the pillars that make a great
survival horror game
atmosphere tense heart pounding moments
resource management atmosphere tense
heart pounding moments
resource management and exploration but
there's a balance that needs to be
struck between keeping the player on
edge but hopeful enough that they'll
survive those insurmountable odds
and make it to the next save point the
further i got into the game the more i
felt
like i was inevitably going to hit a
wall because of the game's relentless
difficulty
which is exactly what happened it's not
often did i give up on a game when i'm
so far
into it but my save file was ruined with
my character having critically low
resources
the game does have cheats so maybe i'll
see it through that way
or maybe i'll start fresh someday with
some insight and see how it goes
because alien resurrection does have
glimmers of greatness
it just needs to balance out his
difficulty
if there's anything that 80s action
movies have taught me it's that any good
strong female protagonist is topping a
jittery shotgun wielding michael beam
hauling cargo across space can be a
pretty lengthy endeavor
so it's a good idea to bring some
entertainment in case one of those
cryopods croaks on you
a good old gameboy never let me down
aliens thanatos encounter is a top down
shooter developed by wicked witch
software for the game boy color
you take control of a team made up of
five marines on a rescue mission
aboard the thanatos freighter it's been
infested with xenomorphs and is up to
you to rescue the crew
and clear 12 stages of aliens each
marine has different stats giving them
different speeds and health points
if you lose all your health you pick the
next available marine from your team
and start from the beginning of the
level but there's still hope for the
previous marine
with the new marine you're given a time
limit to rescue your fallen brother or
sister
this is a cool idea but when you start
as a new marine all the enemies respawn
and i always found the time limit to be
unforgiving
the game offers three control schemes
for shooting one that allows you to
strafe
one that locks you in place as you shoot
and one that lets you run and gun
regardless i still found the controls to
feel clunky and landing shots on the
xenos was always tough
thanos encounter has some cool ideas
with having unique marines
but they could have done with some
refining thankfully the next game takes
that concept and makes it even better
alien infestation is a 2d metroidvania
developed by wayforward technologies
and gearbox software released in 2011
for the nintendo ds
this game follows a group of marines of
the uss sephora
that discover the uss celego after the
events of aliens their mission is to
track down and recover the life form
detected within the ship
along the way they get to partake in
their favorite pastime of killing bugs
and sticking it to the sleazy company
man
i immediately fell in love with this
game first off the graphics are
beautiful
everyone knows that 16-bit graphics are
timeless and can capture different tones
by using the right color palette
even though it has a vibrant look
infestation translates eerie
recognizable locations from the movies
into a more cartoony take they even
hired comic book artist chris bachelow
to illustrate the box art and in-game
character portraits
his art style adds a lot of personality
to each character
just through their designs you can
expect all the usual gameplay elements
from metroidvania games you've played
before
exploration backtracking and gathering
equipment that will help you access
previously inaccessible areas
i'm a big fan of this gameplay loop
though admittedly there's been an
oversaturation of the genre in recent
years
especially in the indie space but i'll
shamelessly admit that slapping aliens
in the title
is more than enough reason for me to
play it although it's very similar to
other games in the genre
i do like that this game has some
quality of life improvements
that i personally haven't seen done in
other games this is obvious given that
it's on the ds but having the map be
constantly available to you since it's
in the bottom screen
is a huge convenience and with a simple
screen tap you switch over to your
inventory screen
smooth you can also drop a flare which
puts a marker on the map if you want to
keep track of any points of interest
this should be in
every metroidvania game these games tend
to have a big sprawling map
and finding your way back to a specific
room can be one hell of a mission
this story follows familiar themes of
the movies with the bigwigs of the
whaling corporation
looking to capture and contain the
xenomorphs for military purposes
you'll explore recognizable settings
like lv426
and the uss celaeko but the game brings
back the cool concept of having
xenomorph animal hybrids
like these bulky eight zenos and what i
guess is supposed to be an elephant
xenomorph
or maybe an alien species that resembles
an elephant
whoa what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
is that an elephant xenomorph
what the hell either way it makes for a
sick boss character
which can be said for just about every
boss in the game these guys can get
really tough to take down
taking up everything in your inventory
before finally hitting the ground
as a 2d side scroller i was worried that
the combat system would end up feeling
shallow
but i found myself getting into some
pretty intense encounters against
xenomorphs when they would come in
numbers
dodging an attack and shooting the enemy
afterwards feels satisfying
i also love that you're able to walk
backwards as you shoot putting some
distance between you and the bugs
you also go up against androids and
human enemies taking out androids is
really simple but fighting the human
enemies is the weakest part of the game
you're incentivized to use this game's
cover system to avoid taking enemy fire
but ducking behind cover and waiting for
the enemy to pop up giving you a short
window to land your shots
is really tedious and slows the game
pace to a grinding halt
running away from a fight is also a
valid strategy especially when you're
low on health
gunning your way towards a save point
while you're on critical health are
really tense moments
the coolest aspect this game has to
offer is this permadeath feature
you start the game with four marines
each with their own personality
that even reflects by having different
dialogue when interacting with npcs
depending on who you're playing as if
any of those marines happens to die on
the field
they are dead dead you then pick a
different marine from the ones you have
left
they essentially act as your lives and
if all of them die on you
it's game over and you have to load from
your last checkpoint luckily
there are other marines that you can
encounter throughout the levels and if
you have an open spot on your roster you
can recruit them
if not then they'll just stay where they
are on the map and you can come back to
them whenever you do have an opening
this is an awesome concept because each
marine has a unique personality
i like certain ones more than others and
i grew an attachment to them
and when they did die i actually cared
and i i
got a little sad for a little bit you
know my favorite character was this
conniving looking guy
he had a smile that rubbed me the wrong
way and i felt like i couldn't trust him
so i put off playing as him and kept him
as a benchwarmer
until his time came and he stood up to
the shady company man trying to
weaponize the xenos
his best interest lied in the survival
of mankind and he sacrificed himself in
a big fight against a super mega alien
queen
he will be missed um
what's his face alien infestation is
another awesome metroidvania that might
have snuck under some people's radar
there are tons of other games of this
kind but i think having characters with
unique personalities to play as
along with the permadeath feature goes a
long way in making this game feel
special
wait how does it know not to track your
motion if you're in the same room as me
doesn't count me moving the thing what
counts as motion
can the air set this thing off because
the wind moves
[Music]
damn it this is what i was afraid of
those things hold monstrosities beyond
what you can imagine
what like a scorpion with a penis
attached to it
that does horrible things to your face
worse
[Music]
[Music]
my god what the hell is that well
it's an interesting combination of
elements making it a tough little son of
a [ __ ]
aliens comfortable maracas is a 2013
first-person shooter developed by the
same studio that brought you borderlands
and also duke nukem forever it falls
more in line with the quality of the
latter
unfortunately aliens collectible
marijuana has been a punching bag for
aliens fans and general audiences for
nearly a decade now known for its
legendarily buggy launch
troubled development full of corporate
politics and its overall negative
reception
sega acquired the license to make a
brand new alien-based game in 2006 and
planned two projects
an rpg action game by obsidian
entertainment that was later cancelled
and a first-person shooter by gearbox
and immediately announced both of these
games
right after getting the license they
hadn't even started making them yet but
they wanted
everyone excited for this stuff for the
fps game gearbox software decided they
were more excited for borderlands and
went to focus primarily on that game
while aliens was left on the back burner
for a few years
then borderlands was a massive success
and they wanted to immediately work on
the sequel to that so they outsourced
aliens to timegate studios who started
working on it in 2010
so everyone involved had the ability to
work on this game for seven years but
procrastinated away
four of it all right now what publisher
meddling oh joy
so sega was like hey make it like call
of duty that's hip right now it's 2010.
and timegate and gearbox were like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about it's a
horror
game the game was also too graphically
intensive to run on consoles at the time
and they had to scale everything
way down to function on xbox 360 and ps3
this resulted in a class action lawsuit
for false advertisement because the demo
for the game looked nothing like the
final product
where have we heard that story before
then gearbox finished borderlands 2 and
finally wanted to give this thing a shot
so they took it back from timegate in
2012
and realized it was really messy and
buggy and not working on ps3 and it was
supposed to release in february 2013 so
they had to just
try to make it work anyway with the
short time allotted somewhere in the
middle there was cancelled and
uncanceled the story was being written
while they were working on levels so a
lot of content was cut or heavily
altered
and gearbox and timegate argued a lot
about who contributed what and how much
of it was whose fault
gearbox's head guy swears that timegate
only contributed about 20 to 25 percent
of the finished game in the three years
they worked on it
while gearbox supposedly did all the
rest
in just nine months if that story is
true then this game was pretty much
made in less than a year given the state
of it at launch that's kind of
believable
the result of this chaotic development
is a messy pseudo-sequel with ugly
and unpolished graphics dead-eyed and
disinteresting characters
stiff and unsatisfying combat and a
story that makes about as much sense as
trying to find a practical use for an
infinitely spawning space monster that
can't be trained or domesticated
so even though the second movie ends
with the colony hadley's hope being
obliterated in a nuclear blast and all
four of our characters taking the solaco
to fly away into space
the game starts with those characters
nowhere to be found
the sulaco is back where it was in orbit
over the colony
and the colony is only lightly singed
the recreation of these set pieces is
cool i guess but the implementation
of these is so clumsy and poorly thought
out
you play as generic ps3 era video game
protagonist number 83
along with a cast of not very well
developed marines checking up on the
solaco
upon entering aliens kill everyone then
you find out once again
weyland yutani is there to harvest and
experiment with alien eggs and six a
force of space mercenaries on you
then you guys fight and crash into the
planet and one of your homies is an
expecting mother for a horrible monster
so you fight your way through hordes of
soldiers and occasionally aliens to find
a way to help her out
fruitlessly i might add strangely enough
this is remarkably similar to the story
of the avp
2010 game up to this point until it
diverges from here when the marines
learn that one of their own is being
held captive by the company
and they're honor bound to go get him
out another interesting factoid about
this game is that its enemy ai was so
broken on launch because of the letter a
[Music]
once that spelling error was corrected
it fixed the majority of the bugs so
unfortunately i can't report that this
game was hilariously broken
it's functional now and just kind of
bland
the aliens attack you and come in nearly
endless waves for video game purposes
randomly there will be special types of
xenomorphs for unique encounters
like these ones that explode and can't
see you the acid spinning ones
and this big one with a cool skull face
that kills you in one hit
they set this guy up to be kind of like
a mr x slash nemesis style enemy
where it would chase you around and the
only option was to run because your
weapons are ineffective
of all the ideas in this game i like
this one the most because i felt some
genuine tension
trying to weld doors shut while this
thing was chasing me or when i was
having to run for cover in narrow spaces
so it couldn't catch me it's almost like
a whole game about that would be way
better
but that just ends in a stilted boss
fight in the power loader midway through
the game that feels like rock'em sock'em
robots
underwater the gunplay isn't fun enough
to keep me invested
the bullet spread on all of the weapons
is so annoying that even aiming down the
sights feels like wild uncontrolled
firing from the hip
in theory that would make the combat
more hectic and stressful while aliens
are bearing down on you but in execution
it's just frustrating that you have to
fire
so many shots for so few to actually
make contact and that frustration
carries over to the human enemies
that's right for long slices of this
game's run time you're battling normal
guys with guns working for weyland
yutani
i think this in the 2010 avp game make
the same mistake of introducing gunplay
with humanoid enemies
for one it's just not scary but it also
contradicts one of the central ideas of
the movie
you know the whole thing where the
marines were a tool for a sleazy
corporation
their lives were totally expendable as
long as it was helping to line the
pockets of some [ __ ] businessman guy
now there's this harsh disconnect where
the marines are the good guy
superheroes and weyland yutani is
outsourcing their evil shenanigans to
faceless mercenaries or androids
in a game that would be more honest to
the source material we wouldn't be
fighting this guy we would be playing as
this guy
but these games don't feel like tackling
themes that lofty so we're shooting
clearly marked white armored halo guys
that are specifically designed to be
distinct from the other generic
gun-toting characters running around
sometimes i forget there are aliens in
this game and that's a huge
problem it dips so far into just being
another dime-a-dozen sci-fi military
shooter game that we saw a million of
around this time
i'll say this game definitely gets
better after the awful first impression
of the first two missions
as soon as you get down on the planet it
becomes a lot more digestible
i still wish the level design allowed
you more exploration this game almost
feels like one of those alien arcade
rail shooters that you used to play in
the before times
it's so linear and you're always having
your hand held by an invincible ai
companion who tells you which things to
shoot at
shoot the fuel tanks around the abc
colloquial marinara sauce would be so
much more
tense if you are alone and isolated with
no companions to assure you or crack
wise the addition of the motion tracker
is neat but it isn't really helpful
outside of just highlighting your
objective marker
it never really added to the tension or
help me get the drop on my enemies
because all of them come straight at you
screaming and flailing their arms like a
joan and vasquez character
in addition to locations from the second
movie that shouldn't still exist
you go to a location from the first
movie the spaceship that's not the one
from prometheus but looks just like that
one
goddamn i don't remember those ships
being that big it's crazy to think that
two different development teams around
the same time built two
totally different versions of this same
set piece one where you're quietly
exploring in a cumbersome spacesuit and
taking in the uneasy atmosphere
and the other where you're throwing
grenades at stormtroopers with your
friend who looks like francis from left
4 dead
so you break into that ship to rescue
the missing marine and find out
alien 3 setup was even dumber because
that guy in the pod was actually a body
double
while wayland kidnapped the real
corporal hicks to interrogate him
for some reason ugh corporal hicks
michael bean himself said that he was
disappointed to work on this game
because everyone involved seemed pretty
dispassionate
that disappointment comes across in his
performance he sounds like he's not
having a great time and the script is so
black that it makes me
sad wish
what information did you give them carl
stuff they're gonna figure out anyway
enough to keep me alive without saying
much it boggles my mind that 20th
century fox still considers
this canon but not the other game that
came out around that time
so now hicks helps us exact revenge on
weyland yutani by stealing their ship
and leaving them in the dust
i'll give this game one thing it had an
actual proper boss fight with an alien
queen where it's chasing you and walking
around
i like how the fight is more about
crawling around in narrow spaces and
finding a clever way to beat the queen
instead of just brute forcing it by
shooting her
it's not perfect but it's the closest we
got the game ends on hicks helping us to
assassinate the head of the company
michael weyland who is played by lance
henriksen
in addition to bishop the other bishop
from this game
carl weyland from the avp game and
charles bishop weyland from the evp
movie
half of the cast of characters in alien
lore just lance henriksen man
we got everything
and with that cryptic and severely
unhyped note
ew that's aliens colostomy marketing for
you
i think making a game exclusively about
marines was doomed from the start
the main point of the movie itself was
that the marines were mostly
overconfident chumps
absolutely bad asses let's pack them in
check it out i am the ultimate badass
guy me and my squad of ultimate bad
asses will protect you
they had their charm and were likable
for sure but the lesson was that for all
their muscles
advanced weaponry tactics and
you mean they cut bravado power how
could they cut the power man they're
animals i want you to with trackers
checking the corners
they were outgunned by an enemy force
they considered to be dumb
savage animals the real star was ripley
all along
because she was clever and cunning and
fighting for something greater than
notoriety or just following orders from
some corrupt suit
she was fighting to save an innocent
little girl and fill the void in her
life
left from the loss of her own daughter
after she was trapped in stasis for so
long that she outlived her
what all these movies and games seem to
forget is that as cool as the aliens and
space marines are
they're all sort of one trick the heart
of the movie was ripley trying to find a
daughter to raise again after the alien
took that away from her
regaining her independence and getting
revenge for the life that she lost
which is why is the first really solid
addition to the franchise in decades
it's not about a mother looking for her
daughter it's the opposite end of that
story
you play as amanda ripley in her 20s
searching through space for any sign of
her missing mother
it's about your mother we think we may
have found her amanda
i know why you're working in the region
where she went missing
you're still looking aren't you there's
even an android here
but he's not lance hendrickson finally
oh my god i was starting to get sick of
that
a ship by the name of the sevastopol is
in the region of space where ripley went
missing and gets a hold of the flight
recorder from the nostromo
naturally ripley jr and a crew of
characters jump at the opportunity to
find out what happened to the ill-fated
space trucker mission
once there they realize everyone aboard
this massive ship has lost their damn
mind and are going full
walking dead survivors grouping up in
teams and killing each other for
supplies or safety while an ambivalent
force of robotic workers prevents them
from getting help
what sparked this catastrophic turn of
events i'll give you two guesses
this game is everything colonial marines
was not it has
heart and emotion it has an interesting
hook it fits well into the mythos and
doesn't obnoxiously retcon a bunch of
[ __ ] to allow for recognizable
levels in game
they wanted to recreate the halls in
various rooms of the nostromo
so they added a ship that's the same
make and model for our characters to
travel to the main setting in
the game doesn't assert that this
explosion only lightly damaged the thing
and it's still perfectly fine with the
same alien in it
that's a perfectly reasonable
justification to get this set piece in
and frankly it's pretty awesome a lot of
care and love was put into recreating
the entire ship to match the movie set
exactly
it's just the place where the tutorial
happens they start you off somewhere
familiar before you get to the resident
evil mansion in space that is sevastopol
this station is cool because it feels
like it's massive and could go on
forever
but it's actually smaller than you'd
think and a lot of its areas tend to
loop back in on themselves once you've
explored it for long enough
it houses many great memorable and
unique set pieces where amanda destroys
her knees by crawling around nervously
while various scary enemies search for
her
they got a lot of the original cast from
the movie back to reprise their roles in
various audio logs and there's even a
dlc mission where you can play as ripley
in a few classic crew
in missions re-enacting scenes from the
movie see you ripley
by right it should have been me going in
there it was my choice dallas
let's get this done they were so
dedicated to accuracy that they even
filtered video footage on the monitors
in the game
through real vcrs to get that messy
tracking look
it's the ultimate love letter this is
not an action game by any means we're
going full
stealth think something more like
amnesia or outlast
you get weapons but they're only useful
against certain enemies while the alien
itself is too tough for anything you
throw at it typically
they rolled with that idea of an
impervious unshakable single enemy
stalking you throughout the game and i
think it was a perfect choice
the alien is finally scary again anytime
you hear a drop down from the vents or
kill some lonely wanderer in the halls
nearby you crap your space pants and
immediately leap into the nearest hiding
spot
your motion tracker racks up the tension
by serving as an additional set of eyes
and ears for you
it's way more functional a stealth
setting when you need a clear idea of
your surroundings the trade-off is that
enemies can also hear the beeping noise
it makes and it's a risk to pull it out
because you never know if someone's
closer than you think and it'll give
away your position
to make it more interesting than simply
sneaking around the alien while he's
distracted
with an important phone call or using
the can you can also guide him by making
racket with these devices
turning on speakers in the distance or
just simply making some noise near a
group of people you desperately want
dead
it's not murder the alien killed them
all i just
accidentally knocked on the wall there
you can also use molotovs pipe bombs
smoke grenades and a hammer to smack
your enemies across the face
the alien is no pushover though and has
some very complex ai that starts to
adapt to your tricks
once you use one gag too many times it
stops falling for it and starts ignoring
the traps or sleight of hand
it can even set traps of its own when
the alien is around the game is for sure
never boring i also love the feature on
nextgen for turning on your mic so the
alien can hear you speaking
sometimes i let out a deep sigh of
relief and a snappy quip when he left
the room
only for him to come sprinting back full
force because i forgot the mic was on
sometimes my cat would also just waddle
in and say hi only for me to get
shredded by the sabby mouth
thanks guys i'll think twice about
running back into the self-destructing
ship to save you turncoats
good to see your friendly face
a neat piece of world building is the
addition of the working joe androids
see most people in the alien universe
were getting tired of all the lance
henriksen's and michael fassbender's
running around with shifting allegiances
so a competitor company created a
cheaper easily identifiable type of
android that would feel safer to be
around now you don't have to look at all
your co-workers and wonder which one of
them could secretly be a corporate drone
hired to break your neck for exposing
your bosses embezzling
it's that one right there [ __ ] that guy
these robots are tougher than average
humans and are just generally unnerving
to be surrounded by if they catch you
i appreciate that they added another
creepy antagonist on top of the alien to
mix it up
they didn't just make it another lazy
variant action figure of the classic
alien
this game's level design ramps up the
tension even more by creating a lot of
arenas for you to hide in from the alien
large circular enclosures with vents and
smaller spaces and waist high cover
where everything always leads back to
everything else
then they throw you a curveball with
scenarios where there's only one way to
go and you're forced to go down a
straight hallway with no hiding places
to get to the next section
i do wish it was easier to navigate
around though because sometimes it's
easy to get really lost
the biggest setback about this game for
me is that it has a length issue
well that's to be expected right most
horror games are pretty short anyway
wait this game is like 18 hour and they
make you
work for it to see that alien initially
you can play this game for like two
hours and not see it then it drops in on
you and you spend like the next nine
hours gasping for air at any chance at a
break from it
it just never leaves you the [ __ ] alone
spoilers here shut up
then you kill the thing and the game
weirdly just keeps going because all the
robots have gone rogan are killing
people by the truckload
and you spend like three hours figuring
that out then the remainder of the game
getting chased around by like five more
aliens
the big twist was that it wasn't one
alien all along but actually a handful
of them
taking turns chasing you what is this a
batman story the game is well designed
and has interesting levels and story
beats and concepts
but god does it start to drag on and on
i'm almost not even sad that this didn't
get a sequel because it's like
2.5 games in one the post alien death
section where you're only dealing with
robots could have definitely been cut
down for pacing
because it runs on for so long that you
once again forget
this is an alien game feels more like a
high budget indie game about rogue
robots killing people in the future
i i i'm not emotionally ready to play
another one of those i still haven't
recovered from last time
but hey how often do you hear people
complain about a well-made game that
gave them too much content
it's long sure but they want you to get
your bang for your buck and have as many
chances to play
unscripted hide and seek with the space
bug in this game as possible
you know because licensed games like
this always have unsure futures
thankfully though you got a really great
scene where sigourney weaver's ripley
sends a final goodbye to amanda before
her 57 year disappearance
and amanda has some heartbreaking
closure to the mystery
we knew the answer all along but it was
important for her to see it
don't worry about me i'm sure i'll see
you very soon
i love you sweetheart
[Music]
signing off oh my god
we all know that in the end she made it
out and lived a long happy life
it gives this scene from the sequel so
much more weight in my opinion
knowing that amanda went looking for her
mother and had a few adventures of her
own
as awesome as alien isolation is it
unfortunately didn't sell well enough to
warrant a sequel
in my opinion it's a gem for the
survival horror genre and well worth it
to play for fans of aliens
or just fans of horror games
well hold on hold your horses we did get
a sequel
just one in the form that no one really
asked for alien blackout was released in
2019 and developed by d3 go
and it is a mobile game furthermore it's
in the style of matpat's famous cash cow
five nights at freddy's hello internet
welcome to a class a disappointment
i was never a fan of the biggest
sensation from six years ago
what do you even call these games point
and click make me flinch-a-thons
survival screamulators not to rag on
anyone that enjoys those games they're
just not my thing
i felt the gameplay was a little shallow
and constricted
unlike the idea of bouncing back and
forth between different cameras looking
down hallways
and making sure that i'm distributing
power to the proper doors
i like to be a little more involved in
the action you know i want to get in
there and get my hands dirty and explore
different environments
not be glued to a chair watching
security monitors
once again we take control of amanda
ripley following the events of alien
isolation she is rescued by crew members
of the mendel station
and she is put into cryosleep to begin
her recovery
while she's peacefully counting sheep
ripley's greatest woes
slaughter the crew among the station and
she wakes up to an all too familiar
nightmare
somehow a xenomorph has invaded the
station also the halden has docked onto
mendel's station
after suffering from damage the
commercial shuttle is carrying two crew
members and two passengers
sado studwick thorncroft and neco yutani
nanku yutani is the second cousin to the
original yutani
and she uses her name to intimidate crew
members and advance through the company
she's like the snotty spoiled rich kid
who feels entitled to everything because
their dad is the manager of the local
car dealership
get over it lady get your boots in the
mud like the rest of us
from here on you're tasked with getting
this group of knuckleheads to safety as
you lead them through different sections
of the mendel station
while avoiding this lanky sob and like i
mentioned before this gameplay style
feels so mundane to me
you're holed up in a vent shaft as you
monitor the crew members represented by
dots on this map of the level
you can draw paths for them to follow to
their objectives and command them to
hide or run if the xenomorph is around
but this often can feel awkward at times
the map is cluttered with different
elements you can interact with
i found myself selecting a different
crew member from the one i meant
or closing a door that i didn't mean to
and it's really frustrating when you
lose a crew member because the controls
worked against you
keeping track of the xenomorph has done
so by using motion trackers placed in a
couple hallways on the map
you can also fend off the xenomorph by
closing doors that will block his path
to the crew members
closing doors and activating motion
trackers use up your limited energy
so you have to pick and choose what you
want activated depending on where your
crew members are in relation to the
alien
this sounds like a fine premise to a
game having this unnerving pressure to
ensure the survival of your crew members
against this unstoppable killing machine
but the first problem is that
i don't give the slightest [ __ ] about
any of these bozos so i might as well be
controlling nameless dots that i have no
emotional attachment to
essentially that's the game at its core
guiding dots to a particular point on
the map
and if a few of them die along the way
the only way to get a fail screen is if
you run out of time or if all crew
members die
you'll miss out on certain dialogue if
not all the crew members are alive for
the next level
but they're better served as
distractions for the xenomorph while
someone else is completing an objective
oh there is also another way to fail
the xenomorph can track down ripley and
face her head on
you'll get an audio cue of it rustling
through the vents and you have to close
one of two before it gets to you
or
i'll admit that hearing the echoes of
the xenomorphs jetting his way down a
vent as it makes his way to you
is pretty scary but again that's because
i'm in direct peril of the monster
not playing security guard at the mall
during the graveyard shift
one of the more prominent aspects that
alien isolation was praised for
was the xenomorph's ai and rightfully so
having a consistent threat that adapts
to the player's behavior
is awesome and terrifying and that's not
at all
here i could honestly never gauge the
alien's behavior
it mostly felt random it would show up
whenever it wanted to
i never felt like it was reacting to
sound or if it would go to where the
crew members were most active
sometimes you would just show up all the
way on the other side of the level for
no apparent reason
it supposedly reacts to you opening and
closing doors but that wasn't the case
for me
for me it felt like it was all left up
the chance so i would just guide my crew
through halls and maybe they'll run into
the xenomorph maybe not
and well that strategy worked for the
most part in a game where you'd imagine
the most interesting part would be
seeing how the alien reacts to sounds
movements and patterns it completely
drops the ball
the best part of alien blackout is its
visuals and audio
it captures the eerie atmosphere of
isolation with dimly lit hallways
beeping computer terminals and echo
event shafts
it's really impressive for a game
running on a mobile device but sadly
you'll be spending more time staring at
this low-tech computer terminal
than using the cameras placed throughout
the level the story is a disappointing
follow-up to isolation
not a whole lot happens after waking up
to find out that the entire crew of the
mendel station has been slaughtered
and guiding the newly docked crew of
holding to safety
we find out that this xenomorph was
being kept in the mendel station
and the ai on board will be doing
everything it can to protect the
specimen
you know usual weyland-yutani malarkey
at the end ripley manages to escape
destroying the mendel station and
setting course to a manufacturing colony
alien blackout unfortunately doesn't
live up to the master class in horror
games that is alien isolation
i'll admit it's unfair to compare it to
a game that is of a completely different
genre
but maybe making an alien game of this
style doomed it from the beginning
this is a niche genre that five nights
at freddy's owns and it garnered this
huge following from it
in my opinion it just doesn't work for
alien i'd rather face the monster head
on and overcome the massive threat with
my wits and endurance
[Music]
just as we were wrapping up editing for
this video travis scott and emperor
palpatine's favorite concert venue added
ellen ripley the alien a power loader
arm a colonial marine drop ship
a chest burster emote and a little
backpack with jones the cat in it
i've never played this game before and i
probably won't after this video is done
but [ __ ] it i decided to get that dlc
and do the predator boss fight since
it's a limited time thing and i've been
caught by a predatory system that
encourages impulse buying and addiction
in small children i am a small child
with poor decision making skills
thank god i can write off v-bucks as a
tax deduction honestly i don't know much
about fortnite because i'm not into
these flavor of the year multiplayer
games but these costumes and models are
really nice and the animated intro is a
fun addition
i actually had a lot of fun playing the
predator mission with friends to unlock
that skin
and i was better at this game than i was
expecting maybe that's because it's a
game for 10 year olds but let me have
this damn it
the alien in this art style looks like a
grown-up version of the dog in planet
51.
it's a little silly seeing the alien
holding a gun but you could always
pretend that he's the android that was
designed to look like a xenomorph from
alien stronghold
jerry the synthetic xenomorph he can use
guns and smoke cigars
and of course it's a really funny image
seeing ellen ripley and a xenomorph
standing side by side in a cramped
hallway
gunning down someone dressed like a sock
monkey with ak-47s
now with the power of modern gaming you
can watch two of the most terrifying
monsters in fiction do the floss
it's alright i guess less of a downer to
end on than the blackout review i
suppose
[Music]
so even though it started out pretty
lame in the old days it just keeps
getting better and better
more dangerous every time we encounter
it it's the perfect organism
nazis soldier your days of hauling
useless cargo are over
now get on your feet and show these bugs
what it really means to be a perfect
organ
a sexual tyrannosaurus
what oh it'll be on your channel don't
worry it'll make sense
what's working on my channel
you